this morning with Tulsa Oklahoma bracing
for a possible political storm tonight
President Trump is not only leading his
first indoor campaign rally since the
pandemic restrictions but the event
itself is defying the recommendations of
the White House coronavirus task force
some businesses spent Friday boarding up
fearing potential clashes between
protesters and police late Friday
Oklahoma Supreme Court rejected a
request to require the wearing of masks
by everyone inside the BOK Center where
the Trump rally will be held Oklahoma
has seen a significant uptick in
coronavirus cases
Omar Villafranca is in Tulsa this
morning Omar good morning good morning
there's actually rain in the forecast
but look behind me hundreds of people
still camped out overnight some of these
folks have been here for days in line
for the first-come first-serve event
as his supporters lined up in Tulsa on
Twitter the President issued a warning
saying any protesters anarchists
agitators looters or lowlifes who are
going to Oklahoma please understand you
will not be treated like you have been
in New York Seattle or Minneapolis it
will be a much different scene Oklahoma
Governor Kevin stit responded to the
president's statements we will protect
your right to peacefully protest there's
a difference now when you start
destroying someone else's property then
we're gonna be there we're going to be
tough on that we're going to make sure
that we hold those folks accountable the
campaign rally continues as the sooner
state battles a surging coronavirus
local health officials are concerned the
site of today's indoor rally holds
19,000 people and the Oklahoma Supreme
Court decided rally goers do not have to
wear masks but team Trump will take
people's temperatures and hand out
sanitizer and masks for those who want
to wear them less than a mile away
Juneteenth festivities attracted
thousands in Tulsa's historic Greenwood
district to celebrate the day slaves
were freed masks are being handed out
for planned outdoor protests and health
officials are encouraging people to wear
them but they are not required more than
100,000 people are expected in downtown
Tulsa for the weekend events there will
also be plenty of security besides the
local police and sheriff's deputies
there are 250 national guardsmen and
more than 200 state troopers on standby
just in case Jeff